hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video von mir meine damen
und herren ich befinde mich hier heute
gerade zwar allein aber reicht nicht
mehr in meine damen und herren wir haben
ja heute einen besonderen gast dabei
nicht im fußball sondern wir haben
diesen fußball jetzt der anhalten das
ist kein geringerer als unter großem
applaus für berlin
[Applaus]
ich habe eigentlich eigenen check oder
schlimmsten zehenspitzen
ja wir machen heute video zusammen auf
jeden fall meine damen und herren der
liebe felix weekends alle bester
schauspieler den skins
felix ist dj und hat ein album
rausgebracht er hat so kreativ wie er
ist das album genannt
ja warum denn irgendwie künstlich ist
verkörpert doch mal selbst dafür stehe
ich mit meinem namen und ein featuring
von uns sind featuring ist auch drin von
lorenz felix jedem wetter smiley auf
jeden fall gibt es dieses album seit
kurzem überall zu kaufen zu sagen ob
spotify findet die links in der
beschreibung allerdings ist das hier gar
nicht primär das thema des heutigen
video sondern eigentlich schon so ein
bisschen wir haben uns nämlich überlegt
dass wir eine google translate challenge
machen film befindet sich gerade hinter
der kamera sag mal helfen
[Musik]
phil befindet sich hinter der kamera und
hat sich einige lieder von dem album
here genommen hat sich die lyrics
angeschaut und habe die in ein dokument
kopiert und andererseits allerdings auch
einige lieder die ist derzeit in den
charts zu hören gibt und diese lieder
werden wir nun in den google übersetzer
hauen und werden dann erraten und
welches lied es sich handelt deswegen
würde ich sagen fangen wir direkt mit
dem ersten sorgen sich dass sie benutzt
wird es halt noch 71 gewinnen aber es
ist ja auch okay es sich an als wäre ich
würde sagen ich dachte dieses 20 okay
war
das nicht ändern kann diese preise schon
durch sein wissen nicht mehr wo ich
musste während du das wort für wort
schon im kopf weiß ja das mache ich auch
aber ich kann nicht lesen
3 2 für felix jetzt kommt der nächste
song und jetzt werde ich aufholen freude
auf ich sehe nicht zusammen aus gibt es
einen grund warum sie die ganze nacht
lag ich weiß wir werden
wer richtig zeigt ja dass dr
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit für den nächsten song
ich bin die ganze zeit bereut du merkst
ich fang frieden seiner gewalttätigkeit
kann den sinn hat 1000 versuche ich bin
zu lange drin gewesen ich war zu lange
stellt ich war zu lang
aber ich weiß nicht ich weiß ist dass es
mir gesagt hast
des wurfes nein groß oder mit seinen
zeilen
das kenne ich nicht es steht 6 0 das war
für den texaner kommt beiden punkt qvc
wofür du sagst nicht weiß nicht ob und
wie wir kriegen natürlich hat mir nicht
gesagt wir können das auch noch
erschweren und ich muss sie können das
machen wir jetzt mal und jetzt das
gericht mehr denn der was ich weiß nicht
was du zu beweisen versucht also schlag
mich oft ist das kann so einfach cool
wenn ihr auf den col des übersetzten
mussten die hit me up das ist nicht
heißt schlag mich sondern das heißt soja
kontaktiere mich oder irgendwie so habe
hier schon gewonnen kanäle gesagt dass
jetzt liegt da kriegt der gewinne zu 100
punkte gehen es ist das blockbuster wie
das auch erwartet
übrigens freunde heute an meinem
geburtstag alle bestellungen
alle bestellungen sind heute
versandkostenfrei also alles in die
schweiz österreich deutschland wenn die
bestellen wollte tut es heute freunde er
wird mir einen riesigen gefallen
allerdings noch nicht genug mit der
werbung denn meine damen und herren sind
wieder eingeblendet einer setzt
natürlich das tolle kiste aus dem lukas
aber andererseits auch das album von
felix sehen die findet es in jedem buch
das ist so überhaupt nicht blenden nicht
so drin
das hier ist er nur noch mit hahn ja
eigentlich müssen wir das cover nochmal
abschneiden also luca gekommen weil ich
meine frisur geändert habe es kann also
freunde wenn ihr euch dieses album hier
kaufen möchte da seien einerseits alte
lieder mit dabei wie irgendwie was ist
damit heuer ganz viele alten wieder
allerdings auch neue lieder wenn ihr das
haben möchte der findet links in der
beschreibung findet felix beschreibung
verlinken finden auf kleinsten sonst
würde ich sagen der stellenwert von euch
dass ihr gefallen hat das gerne mal
einen like da und sonst kommt jetzt das
und kommentiert alle alles gute luca war
ja alle sagte luca ich bin heute 15
jahre alt geworden